r devrait être validé lundi en conseil
des ministres avant d'être examiné deux
jours plus tard à l'assemblée
objectif étendre la mesure aux lieux de
loisirs et de culture dès le 21 juillet
avant les lieux de la vie quotidienne
début août
comme les bars cafés restaurants centres
commerciaux ou encore les transports
devraient rapporter 1 lucas léger qui a
suivi la mobilisation dans la capitale
ils étaient des milliers ici à paris à
répondre à l'appel du leader
souverainiste florian philippot contre
l'extension du pass sanitaire annoncé
par emmanuel macron le 12 juillet
dernier une mesure qu'il juge illégale
inadmissible purement dictatorial c'est
un mot qui est revenue très souvent ici
je vous propose d'écouter ce qu'on a dit
florian philippot qui a qualifié cette
mobilisation de mouvements historiques
la foule parle d'elle-même c'est
historique
voilà il ya un monde fou et d'ailleurs
j'ai vu qu'en france y avait plein de
manif avec plein de monde aussi
en plus on est unis on est rassemblé
des forces qui sont quand même de tous
bords et de tous horizons et ça c'est
formidable aussi et je crois que les
gens disent stop voit la liberté stop à
cette discrimination
stop à cet apartheid stop à cette
tyrannie macro nist il faut arrêter le
délire communiste s'étendent au delà de
la simple vaccination pour peut-être
laissé place à une société de contrôle
généralisé cela suscite beaucoup
d'inquiétude je vous propose d'écouter
ce qu'on a dit nicolas dupont aignan qui
n'a pas hésité à utiliser de mots de
dictature
c'est le début d'un engrenage vers une
dictature c'est un coup d'état
sanitaires c'est l'instrumentalisation
de la peur de la maladie
pour asseoir un pouvoir de plus en plus
illégitime voilà et je pèse mes mots et
je les assume à 100 % or le camp
souverainiste le pass sanitaire est loin
de faire l'unanimité
l'ancienne tête de liste du parti l air
aux européennes françois xavier bellamy
s'est fendu d'une tribune dans le figaro
pour critiquer cette mesure est le
leader de la france un soumise à gauche
jean-luc mélenchon a lui aussi redouter
une société de contrôle qui serait
instaurée avec ce type de mesures quant
aux députés elle est fille françois
ruffin il a lui appelé à participer aux
différentes manifestations qui était
organisée aujourd'hui il ya eu des
appels dans toute la france et à paris
le 14 juillet eh bien les manifestations
avaient engendré 19 mille manifestants
selon les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur
extension du pain sanitaire vaccination
obligatoire toute la journée nos invités
qui ont réagi sur notre antenne écoutez
l'épidémie progresse actuellement de
façon exponentielle avec une
augmentation du nombre de nouveaux cas
de contamination qui se multiplient par
deux tous les sept à dix jours
il ya donc une menace à très court terme
très probablement début septembre pour
que ou revoit une quatrième vague c'est
à dire l'arrivée massive du patient
présentant des formes graves à l'hôpital
de fait pour pouvoir éviter cette
quatrième vague
seule la vaccination permettrait
de protéger les personnes fragiles et un
risque de faire une forme graves ou
fatales
si aujourd'hui on disait écoutez vous
avez l'ebola vous avez une chance sur
deux de vous en sortir quand vous le
contracter je dirais vaccination
obligatoire pas de sanitaires
obligatoires
peut-être même des mesures encore plus
contraignantes aujourd'hui pour le coc
vite ce n'est pas le cas le taux de
mortalité mondiale et 0,0000 28%
il a touché sous le contrôle du médecin
qui nous est groupe essentiellement
jusqu'ici des personnes comme morbide
est plutôt de plus de 65 est encore plus
importante de plus de 84 ans ces
personnes avaient une espérance de vie
moyenne était relativement faible qui
malheureusement a été accéléré et donc
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on arrête de nous
faire peur avec la contamination je
pensais qu'on pouvait attendre jusqu'à
la fin de l'été avant d'imposer la
vaccination obligatoire comme emmanuel
macron la dé facto imposé puisque on ne
pourra plus rien faire si l'on n'est pas
vacciné et que de serre 15 pcr par mois
ou même qu'un ce test quand ils génique
ce n'est pas une vie ce n'est pas
envisagé donc en réalité il ya une vraie
vaccination obligatoire l'apposition du
président se défend de vouloir imposer
la vaccination à tous soit une immense
majorité des plus de 12 ans devraient
être efficaces pour éviter des
couvre-feux et des mesures liberticides
à petit feu pendant encore une année
alors écoutez déjà sept cette loi n'est
pas passée donc il y a encore pour ceux
qui ne sont pas d'accord pour ses
obligations n'en voit pas la logique qui
n'envoient pas l'efficacité
un espoir eux le conseil d'état pendant
un avis très défavorable à cette loi que
le sénat puisse voter contre cette loi
qui à mon sens en tant que juriste est
parfaitement liberticide et se passe
sanitaire inquiète tout particulièrement
ceux qui devront faire respecter la
mesure dans leurs établissements comme
les restaurateurs ils redoutent qu'elle
ne vienne
cacher leur faisons estivale sur
laquelle il mise beaucoup après
plusieurs mois de fermeture
reportage à hervé grand champ et florian
lambert la mise en place d'une forme de
ségrégation
voilà les mots de ce restaurateur pour
qualifier l'instauration du passani
terre depuis les annonces des manuels
macro lundi soir hubert de fight ans ne
décolère pas dans son restaurant à
blagnac il va jusqu'à qualifier cette
future loi de scélérate
la pression est quand même phénoménal
elles mêmes disproportionnée 45000 euros
damende un an de prison ferme
faut quand même avouer que on est dans
une folie législatives de faire peur à
tout le monde on se conformera aux lois
même échelle sont un peu scélérates et
même si elles sont difficiles
on gagnera mais on le fera quand même
parce que nous on appelle néanmoins au
civisme de tous à partir de début août
les clients des restaurants mais aussi
leurs salariés devrait donc présenter un
pass and i ter prouvant qu'ils ont été
vaccinés ou qu'ils ont été testés
négatifs au coc u19 des mesures qui
continue de faire polémique et que le
président de la république justifie par
l'augmentation des contaminations dues
aux variantes delta
le président de la branche de
restauration l'umih 31 noeuds le
confesse c'est à contrecoeur qu il
vérifiera le passé ni terre de ses
clients alors on agira comme on pourra
le faire ça veut dire que si on n'est
pas obligé de contrôler moi je ne
contrôleraient pas il est hors de
question que je me que je
je prenne la place de la police l'état
doit assumer toutes ses décisions
moi si je ne suis pas obligé je ne le
ferai pas recette était passé de 10 ans
sont 12 55 plongé dans l'incertitude le
propriétaire du restaurant l'esprit du
sud ouest ne se voit pas refouler ses
clients après les longs mois de
fermeture imposée par la crise sanitaire
et se demande encore comment il va
réussir à imposer ses contrôles à ce
jour moment où je vous parle nous n'ont
pas cette capacité de police de pouvoir
contrôler on devra faire cela en
espérant bien sûr on nous donne toutes
les modalités le plus rapidement
possible afin qu'on puisse organiser si
l'instauration du passani terre est
considérée comme liberticide par
certains français c'est surtout
l'incertitude et l'inquiétude qui guette
aujourd'hui les professionnels de la
restauration et dans les
pyrénées-orientales la préfecture n'a
pas attendu l'extension d'une passe à
lutter face à la résurgence de
l'épidémie dans le département elle
rétablie dès demain le port du masque en
extérieur la fermeture des bars et
restaurants à 23 heures en
meurthe-et-moselle retour aussi je ne
suis pas du port du masque à partir de
la semaine prochaine selon certains
critères la mesure concerne aussi les
villes de plus de 5000 habitants dont le
taux d'incidence dépasse les 50 cas pour
100000 personnes nouvelles restrictions
sanitaires en espagne en raison là aussi
du var ion delta les autorités et imposé
un couvre-feu dans près de 160 villes de
catalogne dont barcelone une ville
touristique très prisée des voyageurs en
cette période estivale
robin tu es là il est presque une heure
du matin à barcelone ce vendredi soir et
la police évacue la plage la capitale
catalane comme la plupart des villes de
la province est à nouveau soumise à un
couvre-feu
incapable de contenir l'épidémie de kovy
les autorités de catalogne n'avait plus
le choix une décision validée par la
justice un peu plus tôt dans la journée
le tribunal supérieur de justice de
catalogne acte l'instauration d'un
couvre-feu entre 1h et 6h du matin
jusqu'au 23 juillet dans les villes
plus de 5000 habitants où l'incidence
est supérieure à 400 cas pour 100000
habitants
l'objectif sauvegarder et préserver les
droits à la vie et à la protection de la
santé ainsi que la stabilité du système
de santé dans son ensemble
la situation est particulièrement
alarmante chez les moins de 30 ans pour
qui la vaccination a été ouverte il y a
quelques semaines en catalogne
le taux d'incidence a dépassé la semaine
dernière les 3000 cas pour 100000
habitants
après la fermeture des discothèques en
lieu clos la semaine dernière ce dernier
tour de vis du gouvernement catalan
divise dans les rues de barcelone
je suis d'accord avec cette mesure si
les cases sont hors de contrôle parce
que je pense que cela aidera à réduire
l'incidence la plupart des cas sont des
personnes qui interagissent les unes
avec les autres
pendant la nuit je pense que nous sommes
allés trop vite
le gouvernement nous a donné une vision
un peu trop positif de la situation que
les choses allaient bien que les gens se
faisait vacciner mais les jeunes n'était
pas encore vaccinée deux grands concerts
et grands rassemblements sociaux ont
commencé ici et là et il y avait plus
d'infections et maintenant il faut
réguler les choses
je pense que si les choses avaient été
prises plus progressivement nous ne
serions pas obligé de prendre du recul
comme nous faisons maintenant si la
catalogne est l'épicentre de l'épidémie
c'est bien tout le pays qui est touché
le taux d'incidence en espagne a été
multiplié par trois en moins d'un mois
plusieurs régions envisagent donc
d'avoir recours à des mesures similaires
à celles de la catalogne où les ont déjà
instauré entrée en vigueur d'un nouveau
confinement au rwanda pour au moins dix
jours ils concernent la capitale kigali
ainsi que huit districts du pays
des mesures qui s'ajoutaient aux
couvre-feux déjà en place depuis
quelques semaines le rwanda dénombre
environ 800 nouveaux quelques vides
chaque jour réaction de ses habitants de
kigali
comme vous pouvez le constater il n'y a
plus personne
ce qui ici
que pouvons rien vendre cela aura des
effets négatifs mais nous avons à suivre
les mesures préventives jusqu'à ce que
les choses reviennent à la normale comme
ça le confinement est nécessaire même si
ce n'est pas facile pour nous mais le
confinement est nécessaire pour lutter
contre la pandémie parce que cela
réduira le nombre élevé de cas positifs
de décès elisa long suivre les mesures
préventives du gouvernement en australie
sydney durcissons au film ans après
l'augmentation inquiétante du nombre de
cas positifs dans la ville les autorités
ont donc décidé de fermer tous les
commerces donnée essentielle les
chantiers sont également interrompues
les habitants des quartiers les plus
touchés sur une tente et un diction d'en
sortir sauf s'ils travaillent dans le
secteur de la santé ou des services
d'urgence de nouvelles règles en vigueur
jusqu'au 30 juillet prochain sedney
confiné depuis le 26 juin plus de 6
millions de personnes sont concernées
à une semaine des jo de tokyo selon les
organisateurs ont annoncé dans la
journée un premier cas de covin recensé
jeu faussant du village olympique des
organisateurs qui veulent toutefois
rassurants mettant en avant les mesures
prises pour contenir le virus dont le
déroulement des jeux sans public
un huis clos pas suffisant pour calmer
l'appréhension des japonais cité okamba
d'ordinaire fête populaire
les jeux olympiques deviennent
aujourd'hui la cible de toutes les
critiques au japon alors que la
cérémonie d'ouverture se rapproche à
grands pas et que les premières
délégations sont arrivées dans le pays
la décision de maintenir les jo et
toujours vie
heureusement dénoncé par une grande
partie de la population en visite à
hiroshima
afin de marquer le début de la trêve
olympique le président du comité
international olympique thomas ce bar a
tenu à rassurer les japonais ce vendredi
que des amis je suis ici aujourd'hui
pour rendre hommage à hiroshima
la ville de la paix il ya tous les
habitants d'hiroshima les jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de tokyo
2020 seront une lueur d'espoir pour un
avenir meilleur et plus pacifique
le fuel
des paroles qui auront du mal à
convaincre les habitants de l'archipel
l'état d'urgence décrété à tokyo a été
prolongée jusqu'au 22 août prochain en
raison de la propagation du comique 19
des cas de contamination ont notamment
été relevés parmi des personnes liées à
l'organisation des jo dans un sportif
relativement épargnée par la pandémie
la population nippone s'inquiète de
l'arrivée des athlètes en provenance du
monde entier
[Musique]
je trouve étrange qu'il envoie autant de
personnes aux jeux olympiques y compris
la police et l'armée
la façon dont l'argent est dépensé et
mauvaise il ya beaucoup de gens qui
devraient être aidés davantage mais il
ne contrôle que des gens comme nous qui
n'ont aucun pouvoir
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont besoin
d'être contrôlé davantage beaucoup de
choses étranges se passe au japon
aujourd'hui dans l'oeil du cyclone le
premier ministre yoshi des sugar a fait
valoir qu'une annulation des jeux
olympiques coûterait beaucoup plus que
les 12,6 milliards d'euros déjà dévolus
à l'organisation le chef du gouvernement
japonais ne souhaitant visiblement pas
que l'archipel devienne le premier pays
à annuler deux fois les jeux olympiques
soixante et un ans après la renonciation
aux jeux de tokyo 2009 140 nouveaux
pourparlers entre représentants du
gouvernement afghan et des talibans les
deux parties se sont rencontrées
aujourd'hui au qatar au moment où sur le
terrain les combats font rage
l'offensive lancée par les insurgés en
mai prend de l'ampleur facilitée par le
départ des forces étrangères notamment
américaines
un retrait précipité estime au secours
maxime hébert les etats-unis ont échoué
en afghanistan face aux dizaines de
diplomates présents le chef de la
diplomatie russe ne mâche pas ses mots
alors que les forces américaines se
préparent à quitter le pays pour sergueï
lavrov ses 20 ans d'intervention
militaire ont été inutiles chez lui les
américains sont partis comme l'a
confirmé le président byden parce qu'ils
ont considéré que leur mission avait été
accomplie bien sûr il a essayé de
présenter cette situation de façon très
positive mais tout le monde comprend que
la mission a échoué
on dit cela ouvertement y compris aux
états unis eux mêmes
le terrorisme n'a pas disparu de chez
certaines cellules d'al-qaïda ont
renforcé leurs positions en afghanistan
la production de drogue a atteint des
chiffres record depuis mai les talibans
mènent une vaste offensive qui leur a
permis de reprendre une grande partie du
territoire afghan et de plusieurs postes
frontière stratégique avec le pakistan
l'iran le tadjikistan et le turkménistan
face aux insurgés l'armée afghane privé
de soutien américain offre qu'une faible
résistance
pour le président afghan les talibans
bénéficient du soutien des forces
pakistanaises
contrairement aux garanties répété du
premier ministre pakistanais cannes et
de ses généraux selon lesquelles le
pakistan n'a aucun intérêt à voir les
taliban en prendre le contrôle en
afghanistan et en bref comme ils
n'utiliseront pas leur pouvoir
d'influencé pour amener les talibans à
négocier sérieusement les réseaux et les
organisations qui soutiennent les
talibans célèbre ouvertement la
destruction des biens et des capacités
du peuple et de l'état afghan
face à ces accusations
le pakistan a toujours nié soutenir les
talibans afghans
selon le premier ministre pakistanais
son pays a lui aussi subi de lourdes
pertes humaines à cause du mouvement
djihadiste président gagny permettez moi
simplement de dire que le pays qui va
être le fonds touchés dans les troubles
en afghanistan et le pakistan le
pakistan déplore 70 mille morts 70000
sit-in au cours des 15 dernières années
la dernière chose dont le pakistan a
besoin c'est davantage de profits malgré
les tensions entre les deux pays
représentant talibans et afghan se
rencontre à doha pour relancer des
négociations de paix
le processus entamé il ya un an et demi
déjà au qatar sous médiation américaine
est désormais dans l'impasse les
talibans réclament notamment la
libération de sept mille des leurs en
échange d'un cessez le feu de trois mois
une exigence inacceptable pour le
pouvoir afghan
et le gouvernement français appelle lui
ses ressortissants à quitter
l'afghanistan
il a affrété un vol spécial qui a quitté
kaboul ce matin à destination de paris à
bord de l'appareil une centaine de
passagers majoritairement des français
mais aussi des allemands qui ont
travaillé pour la france
vraiment difficile de quitter
l'afghanistan parce que là d'une place
et c'est mon pays c'est ma patrie je
quitte mes parents ma famille mes
proches mais d'autre part la situation
m'oblige vraiment de quitter
l'afghanistan
parce que ces derniers mois
la vie est devenue dangereuse dans
l'afghanistan donc c'est entre les deux
il fallait choisir
donc j'ai choisi de quitter
l'afghanistan et de partir pour paris
pour la france c'est mon pays j'aime mon
pays toujours et aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'on devrait faire parce que je quitte
l'afghanistan pour la sécurité une
nouvelle conférence dead
international pour le liban la france
l'a annoncé hier elle se déroulera le 4
août prochain
depuis près d'un an le pays du cèdre est
confronté à la pire crise économique de
son histoire flambée des prix pénurie et
l'échec de salariés qui n'a pas réussi à
former un gouvernement n'arrange rien
une situation qui a entraîné de
nouvelles manifestations ces derniers
jours aux réactions du co rédacteur en
chef de l'orient le jour
michel toujours marc ce sont des
manifestations un peu normal or les
zones des conditions de vie sur le plan
continue le quotidien qui sont de plus
en plus difficile en raison de la
pénurie d'essence de la pénurie de
carburant de la dégradation de la
détérioration du taux de change d'un
livre libanaise qui a perdu plus que 90%
de sa valeur en quelques mois ce qui
fait que les gens sont de se font face à
une crise sociale et économique et
financière de plus en plus lourdes à
supporter alors ça ça explique
évidemment tous ces mouvements de
protestation qui sont peut-être aussi
fomenté par secteur par secteur mais
nice mais il faut admettre qu'il ya un
malaise social très profond qui n'est
pas nouveau d'ailleurs qui perdure
depuis depuis un an et demi bientôt bien
bientôt deux ans
le bilan des intempéries qui ont frappé
l'ouest de l'europe ne cesse de
s'alourdir
plus de 150 morts dont au moins 1 133 en
allemagne victimes des fortes pluies qui
se sont abattues jeudi sur l'ouest du
pays mais aussi en belgique au
luxembourg et sur une partie les pays
bas provoquant des inondations d'une
rare violence la pire catastrophe
naturelle depuis plus d'un demi siècle
en allemagne où près de 1300 personnes
seraient toujours portées disparues
le récit de ground cesse des images de
désolation dans la ville der stadt blé
sommes situés dans l'ouest de
l'allemagne
un paysage dévasté les pluies qui ont
provoqué un immense glissements de
terrains aux conséquences dramatiques à
should autres villes sinistrées les
habitants encore abasourdi déblaient les
débris avec les moyens du bord comment
on se sent dans une telle situation
désemparée mais il faut continuer nous
nettoyons maintenant regardons ce qu'il
en est dans d'autres maisons qui sont
encore plus impactés mais c'est bien sûr
beaucoup de travail
il faut aussi voir comment ça va se
passer financièrement qu on ne peut pas
trouver les mots
c'est impossible ici tout s'est passé en
deux heures des camping-cars des
voitures ont été pris dans les eaux des
maisons se sont effondrées
en belgique des zones entières ont
également été touchées par les
inondations
là aussi les habitants sous le choc ne
peuvent que constater les dégâts
tout le monde est choqué tout le monde
pleure tout le monde voit seulement
vraiment les vrais dégâts seulement
qu'aujourd'hui et encore la plupart
toujours de dégoûter
j'ai de la chance que je vais dire que
ma famille s'en est sorti comparé à
d'autres personnes que j'ai pu évacuer à
temps
c'est du matériel au final mais je crois
je suis soulagé que tout le monde va
bien maintenant c'est plus pour les
autres familles qui sait puisque et
péniches bédié de nombreuses victimes
sont à déplorer dans ces deux pays
alors que les bilan pourrait encore
s'alourdir en raison d'un nombre
important de personnes toujours portées
disparues
le premier ministre belge alexander de
croo a d'ores et déjà décrété une
journée de deuil national pour mardi et
retour en france cinq ans après la mort
d'anna matra aurait étouffé par des
gendarmes lors de son interpellation sa
soeur à ça continue de réclamer justice
de la mairie de persan jusqu'à celle de
nogent sur oise val d'oise mieux de
l'interpellation fatale du jeune homme
de 24 ans en 2016
le collectif qui réclame justice pour
adama traoré et ses soutiens se sont
rassemblés pour une nouvelle marche
continue nouveaux témoignages et
éléments médicaux recueillis par les
enquêteurs les juges d'instruction
chargés de la faire on d'ordonner un
complément d'expertisé médicale qui
pourrait engager la responsabilité des
gendarmes des gendarmes décoré par le
patron de la gendarmerie nationale en
2019 pour je cite service exceptionnel
une hôte dénonce aujourd'hui
assa traoré sur les côtes bien sentiment
d'injustice
cinq ans après la vérité la nature alors
que nous avons tous les éléments qui
sont là et qui prouve que les gendarmes
sont responsables de la mort de mon
petit frère
nous avons cette expertise qui va sortir
en janvier cette expertise qui a été
mandaté par la justice française par des
experts belges qui vont dire que les
gendarmes sont responsables de la mort
d'adama traoré pendant l'interpellation
nous avons l'impression qu'une pression
est mise sur les gens les experts en
belgique pour qu'il puisse changer leur
avis nous demandons avec notre avocat
maître yassine bouzrou maintenons notre
famille la mise en examen de ces
gendarmes et c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
journal dans une trentaine
deux minutes à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
le président français avait annoncé
vouloir créer un commandement militaire
de l'espace l'espace est devenu
complètement clé en termes à la fois
militaire et en termes économiques
l'espace est devenu un lieu de
confrontation potentiel